une tradition française que l'on nomme à
la tête de la cour des comptes un membre
de l'opposition de façon à ce que comme
la cour des comptes est chargée de
vérifier les comptes de l'état chose de
très important
en nommant un manque de l'opposition on
a ainsi une garantie que les comptes de
l'état sont vraiment sincères
l'opposition à l'assemblée nationale
c'est les républicains s'est passé par
le parti socialiste
un autre élément qui est qui qui fait
peser un doute sur la domination c'est
qu'il ya peut-être un retour d'ascenseur
parce qu'il faut se rappeler je l'avais
noté que le le 5 juin 2019
pierre moscovici à l'époque commissaire
européen avait ouvert une procédure pour
déficits excessifs envers l'italie mais
pas la france
alors que la france avait un déficit
budgétaire supérieur à celui de l'italie
et donc ça c'est extrêmement étonnant et
quelques mois plus tard donc le 25 août
exactement on annonce alors à l'époque
c'était pas encore officielle mon
annonce que pierre moscovici serait
nommé à la cour des comptes
donc est ce pire a pas eu un retour
d'ascenseur c'est-à-dire thermos que
l'uci est sympa et pas très rigoureux
envers la france quand il est
commissaire européen et en échange de
deux de ses de ce laxisme
il est nommé ensuite à un poste très
important de la république la république
française voilà non